également des sujets autour du
consentement de la vie affective au
total 15 femmes du centre ont pu
bénéficier du dispositif enigynéco une
action rendue possible via
l'intervention de sage-femmes libérales
volontaire ils ont pour certaines faits
connaissances pour la première fois avec
ce que c'est qu'une consultation en
gynécologie faire connaissance expliquer
à quoi ça sert de rencontrer un
professionnel de santé expliquer aux
femmes comment fonctionne leur corps et
les pousser tout doucement tout
doucement vers des réflexions un peu
plus poussées sur le consentement sur
leur vie affective et sexuelle je ne
vais darrieussec ministre délégué chargé
des personnes handicapées et Isabelle
l'envirome ministre délégué chargé
notamment de l'égalité des chances ce
sont déplacés jusqu'au centre elles ont
échangé avec les intervenants et
résidents sur l'importance de ce type de
dispositif les femmes sont souvent
invisibilisés invisible mais que les
femmes porteuses de handicap sont encore
plus invisibles il faut que les femmes
pour tous du handicap et les mêmes
droits que les autres femmes il y a deux
fois plus de violences en faire les
femmes handicapées qu'envers les autres
phares des violences en établissement
des violences à la maison des violences
dans les lieux qu'elle fréquentent un
dispositif qui vise à être généralisé et
déployés dans toute la France la
Bretagne la Normandie et l'île de France
sont les seules régions à en bénéficier
pour le moment